ما دلالات ان يقوم وزراء في مجلس الحرب
بصياغه مقترح لتبادل الاسرى في هذه
المرحله وان يقوم بالموزه نتنياهو بعرق
ذلك
الامر نعم تحياتي استاذه السي ومساء الخير
يعني في نهايه المطاف هنا ربما يجب ان
نتذكر ان نتنياهو يتحدث في كل مره يخرج
بها الى الشارع الاسرائيلي هو يحاول ان
يكون الابهام ا الابهام يكون دائما وسيد
الموقف في نهايه المطاف يخرج و في مؤتمره
الصحفي ويضع اللايك جانب كل الاهداف وال
والخطط والبرامج الجاري العمل عليها والى
اين يريد ان يصل من كل ذلك ولكنه في نهايه
المطاف ويترك الشارع الاسرائيلي في حاله
من الابهام وهذه هي التعقيدات التي لا
يراها بعين جيده ايا من الموجودون في داخل
هذا الكابينت يعني قبل ذلك عندما يخرج
جانس في مطالبه بتحديد سبعه اهداف ان كان
بكل ما يخص فيلادلفيا او غيره من الامور
الاسرى وحماس واليوم الذي يلي هذه الحرب
كل هذه الامور اصلا هي الرئيسيه لبلوره
صوره وصيغ لهذا العدوان وفي ظل كل ذلك
نتنياهو يتجنب اصلا الحديث عن ذلك نتنياهو
يخرج الان في خطاب ربما هو يدل على حجم
تعقيدات المساله في داخل الشع الاسرائيلي
يواجه ويقول بانه هو مستمر حتى النهايه او
يعني بكلمات اخرى نهايه حماس ولكن هذه
النقطه والجزئيه الاهم في كل ما يقوله
بنيامين نتنياهو لان نهايه حماس بالنسبه
لبنيامين نتنياهو هي نهايه الحرب ونهايه
هذه الحرب هي بطبيعه الحال هي نهايه هذه
الحكومه فالشارع الاسرائيلي يفهم امر واحد
قبل اي شيء اخر نتنياهو يتغذى من وجود
حماس في داخل القطاع ويريد يعني ان يبقي
حاله من تبييت الحاله العسكريه لكي لا يصل
الى اي من الاهداف الاثنين هو يريد ان
يعتاش من هذه الاهداف هذه الجزئيه
الاولى في كذلك في كل ما يخص قضيه ال
الاتفاقيه والهدنه نتنياهو في الاتفاقيه
الاولى في الهدنه الاولى في اواخر شهر
نوفمبر هو قام بعمليه جس نبض للشارع
الاسرائيلي هل كان الشارع الاسرائيلي ابان
هذه الهدنه سوف يغفر له ما كان ما
قبل السابع من اكتوبر او تداعيات كل هذا
العدوان ام لا بطبيعه الحال وفق
الاستطلاعات وفق القياسات الانتخابيه
الضيقه لم يكن للهدنه اي مو
انتخابي لبنيامين نتنياهو ولذلك تحركاته
منذ ذلك الحين بكل ما يخص شؤون الصفقات
وشؤون الهدن هي فقط تعقيد ذلك اكبر واكثر
بالموزه هناك لهجه تهديديه لنتنياهو تصدر
عن بن كفير الى يعني ما المدى الذي يمكن
ان يذهب اليه هذا التيار المتشدد في داخل
الحكومه من اجل تحقيق مطالبه في تهديده
لنتنياهو
سؤال جميل الحكومات في اسرائيل تنتحر ولا
تقتل يعني كل الامور التي ممكن ان تهدد
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو من الخارج لا يابى
اليها بقدر مخاوفه من هذه التهديدات من
الداخل وانا باعتقادي ان في ظل كل تركيبه
هذه الحكومه بالذات في ظل الاستطلاعات
التي تجري هنالك فقط جزئيه معينه او هنالك
حراك معين في داخل هذه الحكومه الذي يعني
المحرك الاول له هو الايديولوجيه
وليست عدد المقاعد وهو طهار الصهيونيه
الدينيه بمركبه بينغ فير وسموت ولذا
بنيامين نتنياهو يجب ان نتذكر تجربه زخمه
مع هذا التيار في حكومته الاولى في عام 97
عندما انسحب من الخليل عاقبه هذا التيار
في انتخابات 99 وخرج من الحكم للمره
الاولى في حياته وبالتالي هذا المشهد هو
يعلم تبعيات جيدا يعلم ان تهديدات بينغ
فير هي في الواقع اكثر التهديدات التي
ممكن ان تكون ايلاما ولهذا السبب عندما
تخرج بعض التسريبات تحديدا الان وتحاول
استقطاب ليبرمان وتحاول استقطاب لبيد الى
حكومه وزاره الامن القومي التي يتراسها
بينك في هنالك دلالات اثنين في المقام
الاول هو حقا يبحث عن بدلاء لهذا التيار
الذي يضعه في خانه ربما هي الاصعب على
بنيامين نتنياهو لاداره هذه الحاله هذا من
جهه ومن جهه ثانيه هو يقوم بعمليه جص نبض
الى مدى ايه يعني ايه ايه تمسك بينغ فير
وسموت
ب بالمراهنه على الذهاب الى اقصى درجات
هذه الحكومه والتطرف بها والتطرف
بمتطلباته اي بكلمات اخرى هو يحاول ان ي
يجس النبض عفوا اذا من تبعيات هذا الامر
ومن تبعيات هذه الاشاعات يمكنهم ان يتراخى
قليلا في متطلباتهم وواضح جدا ان بينك فير
فقط يصعب المعايير على بنيامين نتنياهو
ويذكره
بابان سبعه 9 عام 97